[Music]
i appreciate you talking to me
i am curious for you guys what's it like
to have
this aspect of your childhood forever
immortalized can you enjoy
going back and watching it or does it
just get too strange
to watch it i don't watch it that often
so every couple years it's kind of fun
to go back
and and relive this event and
as julie says it's kind of like watching
a whole movie
um this was we were all 12
turned 13 during the film so it you
remember
i can remember almost every day you know
on the set what was happening
you know when we were filming so brings
back
a lot of memories but they're all you
know for the most part they're all
positive really good memories christina
it was
for me 12 weeks of my life that is now
out there
forever for everybody to see but as pete
says you know i remember the thing you
know the little
tiffs that we might have had amongst
each other you know oh i was feeling a
little bit grumpy that day and
oh yeah i can see that little smirk on
my face i know what was going on that's
not acting you know
so it's just funny it's just funny to
see that home movie hear my voice
um see how i was you know i've got kids
now that's kind of extraordinary
it's a legacy for them as well um you
know
see mummy growing up and when my
daughter was the same age it's like
oh my goodness she looks like me or i
look like her or whatever it is and then
now i have a granddaughter so it's
extraordinary kind of chain that goes on
and of course the other thing about it
as a home film is that
it has all of the advantages of a
production right so whereas
you know of course now everybody's
taking pictures of everybody so we've
all got a lot
of photos of each other but at the time
unless your dad happened to be a super 8
geek you probably wouldn't have a movie
in the first place
and if you did it certainly wouldn't be
on huge sound stages well lit
well directed with full costuming and
all of the production elements so
uh in that sense it's an advantage now
having said that
uh speaking for uh julia and michael and
i we weren't necessarily
putting our best personality forward but
uh
in any case uh it's still nice to have
it all preserved for uh
for posterity
michael how about for you do you revisit
it or do you avoid watching it
i run a little tax office in munich and
we spent every christmas the last
workday together with my employees
and every two or three years i have a
show the wanker movie
because the film is not famous in
germany
and my new employees have to know what
to start their bosses
hey michael i didn't know you did that
when are we coming to you for christmas
yeah come it will be a drinking
champagne and you get very good food
we'll be your star guests we'll be very
happy we'll eat the bread first and i'll
have the beer and we'll be fine
yeah i love it well so obviously the
most important question is did you guys
actually have
access to candy on the set i know that
the chocolate river was water but was
there
a set full of candy otherwise or was
there a surprising lack of candy on this
set
power grounds we are real and german
donuts very old
donuts were fantastic they're a
sauerkraut not so much
i would say a surprising lack of
candy um but pretty much everything that
we ate was real
everything else like the gummy bear the
ear was
was edible but the entire gummy bear was
not
so um yeah it uh
there was not as much edible food on the
set
as you might think and also surprising
because we were in germany
uh right next door to switzerland and
all in there they make gorgeous
chocolate and uh yet they shipped uh
hershey bars
to us from america uh almond joys mounds
this sort of thing from america so that
was a bit of a
crime against uh chocolate and humanity
that they did that
but um uh yeah uh there were definitely
uh
things for us to eat little uh uh gummy
leaves and uh some marzipan
things i liked the
gum which wasn't gum it was actually a
taffy
in the um it was the three-course gum
which wasn't it was a taffy but it was
very yummy i liked that one
i think that's really interesting
because in your memory as a child you
think of us going in this factory and
eating everything
if you take the movie apart as an adult
and look at it frame by frame or scene
by scene
we don't eat anything because we're not
supposed to so we were able to eat
you know some of us didn't and we were
but we were able to eat
the only time we were invited to try
everything was in the chocolate room
so that was one week of like eat what
you like
but then you only were able to eat what
the props man gave you and what they
decided so there was a little bit of
kind of
competition to sweet talk the props man
to give you the
the thing that you liked you know paris
got the gumballs from the tree
and denise got the gummy bear and i got
that chocolate watermelon
what are the memories that most stand
out for you guys from working with gene
wilder and being around him on set
is there a moment that you shared with
him during filming that most
stands out for each of you guys my final
scene
with gene when charlie gives back the
everlasting gobstoppers the scene that
i'll remember um that was the most
intimate scene
between charlie and and willy wonka and
uh
so it going back in in my mind
that was uh a special day working with
team
and kind of you know it brings you know
it's the conclusion of the film it
brings
brings the message home when charlie
gives back the
everlasting gobstopper i enjoyed being
his
his foil uh i don't know which of us
would have been the straight man but we
had a lot of encounters
in the film where he was playing off of
me things like when he took the
the hair out of my head at the bottom of
the stairs in the chocolate room
uh too many takes let's get that joke
made
um or the time uh when uh mud easter's
over and
slaps his heart across my my mouth or uh
you know i'm a trifle definitely
you know there's several things that he
uses me for
as a way to sort of uh express his
character so uh
it was fun to play against the master
yeah such a kind man i was just as we've
talked about this and i'm trying to
think of things that i've never thought
of before and obviously my big moment
was my
my song you know singing i want it now
and
you know in my mind i can remember you
know the pressure of
you know the only other song that we'd
had so far
that we'd seen or we'd been part of was
jean's song
uh you know pure imagination and then
we'd had the ompalumpa songs
i wasn't there when the candy man was
was done
or when peter did this so suddenly it's
like oh my gosh this is my moment
and how um how nice jean was
at that time you know it was my 13th
birthday he was really kind of sweet
but i just remember him being really
reassuring and i do remember him saying
to me you know
are you okay now is everything okay for
you you know it's a
big deal to do a solo number in a movie
when you're 12.
um and and following gene
so yeah i just remember that and i i've
got some pictures that actually just
only surfaced recently of him kind of
just standing back and watching
and thinking oh that was that was quite
nice that he just kind of went
over to you very generous well i just
remember making an interview machine
they were sitting on the staircase and
uh gene doesn't speak english and
i doesn't speak german i don't speak
english and the newspaper
girl doesn't speak english at all so it
was really funny and he was very gentle
to me
he made the best out of the situation
and he was
very kind what's it like for you guys to
see
not only that there was a remake done a
few years back
with johnny depp in the role then
now there's gonna be a new movie that
focuses on a young willy wonka when he
met the oompa loompas
what is that like for you knowing it's
still sort of all connected to something
that you guys were a part of
and that it's lasted this long um yeah
i think it's extraordinary and it and
it's it's great there's room for all of
us
you know and it kind of keeps the
interest going
and what i like and that nobody can take
away
we were the first uh agreed you know
it's not just
those uh specific things i mean uh
certainly there was a broadway show
peter i think you mentioned there was a
there's an opera i hadn't heard that one
there's an opera yes
of willy wonka or of charlie of willy
wonka yeah
okay okay i didn't know that but there's
always side door stuff there's
you know american idol has got golden
tickets and uh
you'll see a simpson thing or a family
guy thing i mean you're collider you're
pop culture people so you know what i'm
talking about there's
it's constant there's uh which ad
campaign is now using candyman i think
it's
a t but there's always something
happening and uh
uh that's a good thing you know uh we
all have very positive associations with
the film so
we welcome more and more um
david heyman uh is of harry potter
ilk and uh timothy chalamet that's you
know he's a class act
so um i'm hopeful about the next one
yeah i i appreciate you guys talking to
me i mean it's it's always lovely when
art inspires art because then it means
it affected people in some way
so thank you exactly exactly i
appreciate you talking to me about the
film it's always been a favorite of mine
so thank you guys
very good thank you very much